momento para hablar de economía aquí en
Francia 24 ya me acompañan en el estudio
Jorge Hurtado Jorge muy buenas noches
comenzamos hablando de Esos planes de
reforma del fondo monetario
internacional y el Banco Mundial que
propuso el presidente macrón en su gira
por Estados Unidos lo estábamos
mencionando en el bloque de noticias y
así ponen en Manuel macron que está de
gira en ese país dijo que los diseños de
los proyectos de ambos organismos y su
enfoque ya no están adaptados a la
magnitud de problemas como el cambio
climático la solidaridad y el cambio
climático en su opinión son dos
conceptos que van Unidos para macron uno
de los puntos clave de la estrategia
climática debe ser ayudar a los países
emergentes a liberarse de su dependencia
del Carbón la visita de Manuel macron se
da mientras aumentan también las
tensiones en torno al comercio los
europeos ven como una preocupación esta
ley de reducción de la inflación de
Estados Unidos y temen de una ventaja
injusta en sectores que se tambalean Ya
de por sí por las consecuencias de la
guerra en Ucrania y los intentos también
de Occidente acabar con la dependencia
del suministro energético ruso vamos a
escuchar Así que decía el presidente
macrón
tenemos que reformar tanto al fmi como
al Banco Mundial y creo que esta es una
agenda extremadamente importante para
Estados Unidos y Francia creo que la
forma en que colectivamente asignamos
nuestro dinero la forma en que diseñamos
nuestro proyecto y usamos el dinero para
el cambio climático y la solidaridad ya
no se adaptan en términos de magnitud y
en términos de tecnicismos
Yo creo que es la noticia que no
queríamos oír Jorge pero habla el
presidente de la reserva Federal de
Estados Unidos sobre el aumento de los
tipos de interés que dijo Bueno Power le
aseguró que subirá los tipos de interés
más de lo previsto y los mantendrá en
ese nivel durante un mayor tiempo esto
como parte de la lucha contra la
inflación sus comentarios ayudarán a las
expectativas de que la Fed suba los
tipos de interés en 50 puntos básicos
cuando se reúna el 13 y el 14 de
diciembre próximo recordemos que el
banco ya lleva cuatro movimientos
consecutivos de 45 puntos básicos son
las acciones de la Fed las más agresivas
desde 1980 y elevaron el rango objetivo
de su tipo de interés de referencia
hasta el 3,75% y el 4% cuando por
ejemplo en marzo de este año era de casi
cero escuchamos a Jerome Power uno de
los personajes más seguidos por los
inversores la verdad es que el camino
que queda por recorrer para la inflación
sigue siendo muy incierto por el momento
dejemos de lado las previsiones y
fijémonos en las condiciones
macroeconómicas que creemos necesarias
para que la inflación baje al 2% con el
tiempo para empezar necesitamos subir
los tipos de interés hasta un nivel lo
suficientemente restrictivo como para
que la inflación vuelva al 2%. seguimos
hablando de Estados Unidos porque la
cámara baja de ese país aprobó evitar
por ley una huelga ferroviaria que
tenían diferentes sectores del país la
cámara lo validó por 290 votos a favor y
137 en contra los sindicatos y los
representantes del sector ferroviario en
Estados Unidos acordaron en septiembre
pasado un pacto provisional que
contempla un aumento de salarios el 24%
para los empleados así como cláusulas
para permitirles ir al médico o
responder emergencias familiares de ser
sin ser de algún tipo penalizados los
trabajadores de ocho sindicatos votaron
en los últimos meses a favor de ese
acuerdo pero otros cuatro lo rechazaron
y en los últimos días amenazaron con
convocar a un paro a partir del 9 de
diciembre justo antes de que inicie esta
temporada navideña El presidente Joe
biden había advertido de que esta huelga
podría ser devastadora para la economía
de su país pasemos ahora a temas de
Europa porque en la eurozona la
inflación interanual cayó seis décimas
en el mes de noviembre ahora se ubica en
el 10% anual y En comparación con el
10,6% registrado el mes anterior y que
marcó un nuevo máximo histórico en los
países de la moneda como en los datos
preliminares que fueron publicados por
la oficina de estadísticas comunitaria
libertad muestran la primera
desaceleración desde junio de 2021
cuando la inflación anual fue del 1,9% y
luego comenzó esta espiral ascendente
que hasta ahora da solamente un leve
respiro pasemos ahora temas de la región
Jorge hay tensión en ese posible o esa
previa Cumbre del mercosur Por qué bueno
Y es que a Argentina Brasil y Paraguay
amenazaron con represalias a Uruguay si
insisten en negociar acuerdos
bilaterales sin la autorización del
bloque en una carta conjunta los tres
países se quejaron de que el gobierno de
Luis la calle Pau Busca negociar
acuerdos bilateralmente pero la atención
aumentó esta semana con la gira del
canciller uruguayo Francisco bustillo en
Australia y Nueva Zelanda para sumarse
al acuerdo transpacífico el resto de
países argumentan que los estatutos en
mercosur prohíben que cualquiera de los
cuatro socios del bloque cierre acuerdos
extra zonas sin el resto el presidente
de Uruguay respondió que en su país a su
país lo asiste el derecho internacional
dijo y que va a entregar su pedido de
adhesión al Tratado integral y
progresista de la asociación
transpacífico pese a estas amenazas de
los otros países hay reacciones también
del presidente de Paraguay Mario abdog
quien dijo que la intención de Uruguay
desnaturaliza la esencia del bloque
suramericano Uruguay también ha buscado
negociar un acuerdo de libre comercio
bilateral con China la reunión
comenzaría del mercosur la próxima
semana y se esperan más reacciones en
torno a esta disputa ya veremos En qué
termina esa disputa Jorge muchas gracias
por esta actualización del mundo de la
economía a continuación en directo
América el debate
[Música]